Es ist wohl so relativ oft gibt es einen schlimmen ausbruch der sonne einen sonnen hurrikan ein
sondern ausbruch und das wurde jetzt berechnet würde das gesamte stromnetz der erde ernsthaft beschädigen und zwar so schlimm dass der
wiederaufbau und das ist hier die einzig passende bezeichnung vier bis zehn jahre dauern würde schaden laut dem versicherer lloyds
2,6 millionen dollar und das wären die folgen eines schwachen sturms wie wahrscheinlich ist ein solcher sturm was passiert bei einem
Sonnen hurrikan der viel schlimmer ist jetzt sind klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Das event war so ein schwacher sonnenstürme
859 beobachtete der britische astronom richard kärnten einen
ausserordentlichen strahlung und teilchen ausbruch auf der sonne telegrafen leitung hier auf der erde sprühten
Im anschluss funken und nordlichter waren auf kuba jamaika unter weit, zu sehen eine solche
sonneneruption würde heute aber einen deutlich höheren schaden anrichten und das stromnetz würde weltweit stark beschädigt werden die folgen wären dramatisch
Und die kosten lägen bei den genannten
2,6 billionen dollar einen vorgeschmack lieferten die sonnenstürme 1989 und 2003 damals fiel der strom
Im kanadischen werk aus die
gps-signale
wurden so stark gestört dass flugzeuge sich nicht mehr danach
orientieren konnten und 1 600 millionen dollar satellit wurde zerstört in den usa hat der kongress
2015 deshalb einen aktionsplan zum weltraumwetter beschlossen um die folgen eines solchen sturz abzuwenden doch
bisher laufen diese pläne ins leere weil man einfach nicht weiß wie man sich vor solchen sonnenstürmen schützen sollen bzw
Einen es einen massiven umbau von allen radverbindung und vor allem des stromnetzes in den usa bedeuten würde dazu
Gibt es aber noch keinerlei anstalten und in europa wird einfach gar nichts getan und die wahrscheinlichkeit dass uns demnächst ein solcher sturm trifft
Ist mit 10?
sogar relativ groß wie drei lief vom forschungsunternehmen
protective science
Im kalifornischen san diego hat dazu die daten vergangener sonneneruptionen ausgewertet und ist zu diesem ergebnis gekommen
aber auch ein massiver sonnen hurrikan ist demnach gar nicht so unwahrscheinlich
fuss anja physiker an der nato der university in japan und sein team hat 2012 in drei
jahresringen massiv erhöhte werte von kohlenstoff 14 c14 gefunden die auf eine sehr große sonneneruptionen
einen sonnen hurrikan schließen lassen das war in den jahren
774 und
775 also vom märz 1000 jahren damals gab es noch
keine kabel keine satelliten und so weiter die auswirkungen dürften minimal gewesen sein und jetzt haben manas wie lehm und
erblüht von der amerikanischen harvard university in einer aktuellen forschungsarbeit
145000 sonnenähnliche sterne angesehen sie haben die daten des kepler
weltraumteleskops analysiert und dort bei den untersuchten sterne nachgesehen wie oft solche super ausbrüche solche superflex
Stattfinden und ihre ergebnisse sind ernüchternd alle 2000 jahre
finden sie
im durchschnitt stadt
statistisch haben wir also noch zeit aber die
Wahrscheinlichkeit für einen solchen sonnen hurrikan ist da und steigt stetig und bisher gibt es keine einzige idee was wir dagegen tun können
Die folgen wären dramatisch die gesamte weltwirtschaft würde nahezu zum erliegen kommt die schäden wären im zweistelligen
Millionenbereich es wäre wirklich wirklich schlimm aber lob und linken haben eine idee ein riesiger draht ring zwischen erde und sonne
Er wird vom strom durchflossen und lenkt die teilchen und die strahlung ab gewicht
100.000 tonnen kosten rund 100 milliarden dollar aber ist so ein großes projekt überhaupt möglich es wäre quasi
Unsere erste alien mega struktur und es ist möglich so viel hat nämlich die internationale raumstation
Alles in allem gekostet wenn ich sogar mehr es ist also möglich
aber ich fürchte dass wir vielleicht noch den einen oder anderen sonnensturm hier auf der erde
Erleben müssen bis die menschheit hier aktiv wird wenn es neues zum thema gibt dann erfahrt ihr es natürlich hier drückt mir dafür hier
Ein aber aufs auge und vergesse nicht den genau auf die glocke denn wir dann verpasst ihr nämlich kein video hier geht es weiter mit
Alien mega struktur aufgeklärt dafür auf das video klicken und ansonsten bis dann
begann